[Music]
foreign
I love it I love Joe Rogan I love the
fact that he can be like whoever he is
and invite whoever he wants here I'm
pretty excited about it because Joe
Rogan at this point in his career is
uncanculated you can't cancel Joe Rogan
therefore you've got an amazing comedy
club and it's also full of uncancelable
amazing people I think what Joe Rogan is
bringing to Austin is a pure freedom of
speech I think it's a very big deal that
Joe's opening his own club I mean it's
providing an opportunity for people to
come and speak their mind for free
speech without fear of repercussion or
being canceled and reminder that comedy
is supposed to be funny everyone's here
to have a good time and that's really
what this is the embodiment of is Free
Speech all of his shows are always great
so him opening his own thing I know it's
going to be a huge hit down here I think
it brings a different crowd of people to
Austin and I think it brings a new vibe
to the street I think what Joe Rogan is
doing with this new comedy club is uh
letting the audience decide what we can
still say and what's still funny while
it's certainly good for Austin but I
would say it's even good for the country
I think right now we are in a point
where everyone it's canceled culture
everyone's afraid to speak up everyone's
afraid to speak out and having a place
like this where folks can come and just
joke around and have a good time and not
fear repercussion or fear that they're
not going to be booked again or anything
like that it's it is truly freedom of
speech and it's good for Austin it's
good for the country it's good for Texas
it couldn't be better joburg is a huge
name in comedy so he brings a lot of
different people here because he's
friends with everybody I think it would
be good to get a new crowd for comedy
and say this is a more liberal City
maybe expose them to that type of comedy
and bring in a new group of people